Aaron brought you on because you are the
resident division expert of the office a
game that has undergone many changes
since March might released its like it
almost totally different now yeah um
division just released their survival
DLC on their public test server only on
PC and only on you play for the moment
it's how they tested their 1.4 patch
that game super interesting because like
survival fixes a lot of things that the
core game got wrong in my opinion
although it is standalone it's it's
actually something you do and then you
come back to the core game and get loot
but like the core game of the division
was always a game that everything in the
game screamed at you like this is a
survival game but nothing in the game
was survival right there was just all
this extra stuff you collected and it
gave you buffs against NPCs or like you
had all this random clothing that wasn't
really all that interesting and didn't
have any stats like a normal RPG would
so in survival you get dropped in clean
with like none of your gear on to the
core map it's the whole map and your
goal is to make it to the dark zone and
get extracted so you can play with 24
other players against the environment or
you can play against 24 other players
sure and this also like comes on the
heels of update 1.4 which we brought you
on to talk about on the lobbyists well
month or two ago which that was like a
lot of quality of life improvements and
made leveling up your gear and your
actual the loot system more rewarding
and useful in the long run right and
then that survival got delayed because
of that they wanted to make sure that
stuff rolled out to make the game like
more playable before they release this
but this sounds like like you were
saying it sounds very much more like
because the main appeal for me and I
think Pete mean you always talk about
this the division is kind of appealing
to me because of its world I really like
that like you know Christmastime
post-apocalypse host apocalyptic
manhattan but the game never grabbed me
i've only played like two hours of it
total and every time something like this
comes out at it makes me want to it
brings me back in potentially and this
kind of survival bent seems like the
thing that could pull me in so like you
played it on PTR right and it's
available only through you play right
now yeah on their public test service
what did you think about it overall
it's interesting also like I came off
playing a bunch of king of the kill
before a lot of the Triple A titles came
out so I was I have like another good
sort of Survivor shooter to compare to
for a king of the kill which is that
h1z1 standalone did you start in a like
an eight kilometre square zone you all
end up and you scavenge way to the
middle men kill each other right so like
one of the interesting things you have
to look at in a game on the PvP version
of survival is player density and I
think that's something they're gonna
have to mess with a little bit because
like in a survival game you want people
to have to worry about the environment
and and have enough player encounters to
be scary but not so many that it's
pointless and you'll just die right away
right right and that player density per
area is really important you can also
play this just with other players again
so you're not you don't have to worry
about that aspect of it but it's
interesting because i think the loot was
the loot in the game was slightly better
and the npcs were slightly harder when
you were just playing against the
environment so they've balanced it both
ways although in the overall game world
you get more points for playing against
other players um so you're contending
with things that the core game should
have had you always contending with like
the you know it's a virus ravaged city
and you were never never to worry about
in the first game you're just like
whatever like you were just immune
automatically sticking rusty nails in
your arms and like picking up guns and
licking them halfway through the game
like it just how did you play this you
might be doing of Mad Max and a lot of
ways open the just activities you've
described but also like the disconnect
between like wait how am I supposed to
be able survive in this like it's hard
to imagine how you can actually capture
that so like could the survival mode
somehow be integrated into the main game
or do you think that that's just like so
impossible at this stage to me it's a
reimagining of the core game in a weird
way like I almost I would love it if
they would pour this into the core game
itself but you might get rid of the
people who are just there for the lou
grant because you're adding a lot of
extra survival elements such as viral
infection hunger thirst having to worry
it's having to worry about a lot more
things than just I know like you know
again air k plays these games the
opposite of the way that I do
maxing and will not rest he goes for the
most efficient run for the most loot in
any given session right so survivals
more about the experience of the world
you're in a blizzard you're freezing to
death and you're trying to make it to a
goal without dying and the everything is
trying to kill you including you know
including your own health your own
health bar at some point starts taking a
hit you can start freezing to death you
can starve and then not be able to
regenerate your health so it's it's not
like it's not like a new genre or
anything but I think it's kind of what
the division it's what the original idea
of the division was the world calls for
ya think well that's why i was wondering
like i am i right in assuming that like
enemy placement each time is procedural
or is that like set spots where enemies
are gonna come out because you what you
described to me earlier sounds like
something that has an interesting
risk/reward factor where i get dropped
in by the helicopter I think the
helicopter crash at the beginning that
justifies why you're like fighting
toward the center you're affected your
battling cold I know gear has like the
cold rating that are the warmth rating
whatever it is yeah and it sounds like
there be an interesting risk/reward like
you mentioned earlier we were talking
about this like you're in this firefight
and like each minute that passes during
this firefight if you're not killing
these guys and moving on you're gonna
start to panic because if you're like
you might be doing well against these
guys where they're taking too long so in
the cold is just going to start eating
at you but then you also have to contend
with thirst which affects your vision
vision I think you're saying which
that's gonna make the fire fights harder
is there an interesting kind of risk
reward angle to spending time in certain
areas as opposed to just you know
rushing through and risking the fact
that you might not have the good enough
gear to fight the harder npcs toward the
center of the map yeah i love how
intentional all of your decisions
suddenly become in the game like before
you were just aimlessly running through
a like for no reason just running from
point A to point B here you have to
chart your route it's like I know that
there's fire here here and here I know
there's a safe house there I've got
enough thermal protection to make it so
that's set but halfway through that I
run into NPCs it's what you said how
cold am I how hungry am I like but how
much health do I have in reserve and
then there's other cool things like the
shield and the game was always useless
but suddenly when you can't regenerate
your health because you're starving
having the shield ability blocks a lot
of the incoming damage
so it becomes a significant piece of
gear that was not significant previously
so this and because you have limited
resources and you have to craft all of
these things including your own
abilities it just becomes a much more
intentional game and takes a lot more
planning for you to get places it seems
like it kind of requires you to be much
more proactive pretty much every step of
the way rather than just kind of letting
things happen throughout your time in
this world and that's what interested me
because at the same time it's really
cool how far the division has come at
least like from what you've said well
from what I've read I saw this like
long-form story somewhere recently about
the behind the scenes and how much work
you be soft is continued to put into it
but at the same time it's also kind of
indicative of the problem a lot of
people have now with like early access
games or just games getting released and
then you know like the criticism that
they're not complete they're just
releasing them in completely and then
you know patching them afterward I don't
know where do you fall on this I mean
it's not like you're enjoying the game
more now than you did like multitudes
more than you didn't march right and it
sounds like something I would enjoy more
again I can't speak to accept played it
much but I know where do you fall on the
game being like like really engaging fun
to play now as opposed to march like I
don't know like does it feel like this
is what the division was supposed to be
this is the first time that I've enjoyed
DLC in the division to be honest like
underground was basically just a loot
factory for four players which was cool
like players needed a loot incursion
they should have just called a room I
thought that was a really kind of fast
attempt like the first time you've gone
to an incursion and you're like oh I'm
in the room and this is where the whole
thing happens that's kind of lame so
this is the first time they've actually
tried to reimagine the game in an
interesting way and it's probably safe
that it's a separate experience and that
you come back to the core world of the
game afterwards with loot depending on
how you did but I think for people who
enjoyed the single-player portion of the
game whom who hated the dark zone and
who were not into the loo crime
necessarily this is the first this is
what i would consider the first piece of
new content for them but the first new
single player expansion even though to
be fair it's on the same map but the
blizzard makes it feel kind of new again
and you said that you yourself would
recommend people play this
own and not against 24 other players I
would definitely start with the PVE
section with the PvP section people can
still team up and I think you'll run
into the same problems you do in the
dark zone where you just get stomped
with no hope of winning there's no real
good balance in this game and that was
one thing destiny did really well out of
the game was make sure that their PvP
was balanced regardless of how good you
were outside of their core like some of
their core modes you have to voluntarily
go to but when the end game of the
division was a place that you just went
and got annihilated with no hope I think
that's why a lot of players left sure so
you have the choice here of going to
essentially what amounts to a dark zone
and not get annihilated by other players
which i think is a better experience for
the people who hated the original dark
zone right yeah this I mean it comes out
kind of almost at a time when I would be
willing to jump back in right away but
you know you have like dishonor to you
have watchdogs to you have I don't know
Final Fantasy dead rising for on the way
out almost would have preferred if they
did delay it or they already delayed it
I almost would prefer them to release it
like mid December something that's just
me being selfish but I I've had the
weirdest itch to play this game ever
since I played like two hours of it back
in March or April or something and is
the same discussion I have every time
around this game because it I can't read
me before it released and then you know
a scott reviewed i think and you know he
for like despite its air like its flaws
he really liked it and he enjoyed the
world and he said like the grind like
despite it being grind you felt really
worth it you know in the end but i don't
know like now the fact that like he were
saying the world itself seems like it's
pulling you in more i kind of this might
be when i finally jump back into it like
i have co-op partners its gameplay
consorted man like that that's so much
more attractive to me than i think what
i was playing before yeah for sure and
this is the penultimate dlc the next one
will be the last stand or just last
stand which is you know appropriately
enough the final expansion and that was
scheduled to come out around this winter
but is now two out in early 2017 so yeah
aaron thanks so much that is the
division that is survival dlc that is
does not have an actual release date yet
by the end of the year end of the year
sometime before you know like new years
and it is also available now through you
play on pc for some players and let us
know you think well you
we get back into the vision is this
someone something that I keep you
playing amid the other huge fall
releases leave your thoughts in the
comments below